on tourne c'est donc aujourd'hui que
l'on saura quelle est exactement la
nouvelle répartition des sièges à la
douma
tout à fait les résultats officiels sont
attendus un petit peu plus tard dans la
journée en ce moment la commission
électorale explique un petit peu les
modalités de ce vote et en particulier
en ce moment on y discute on y analysent
le vote en ligne à ce propos la
commission électorale a fait savoir que
les résultats de ce vote en ligne se
montrer cohérent avec les résultats du
vote physique et ce dans les sept
régions où ce vote en ligne a pu avoir
lieu donc je vous dise il faudra encore
attendre un petit peu avant d'avoir les
résultats officiels en attendant on a
déjà une bonne idée de cette répartition
d'après les résultats préliminaires le
parti au pouvoir russie unie devrait
s'adjuger les deux tiers des sièges de
la douma entre les candidats qui ont
gagné qui ont remporté leur
circonscription et la part de
proportionnelle en deuxième position va
arriver le parti communiste suivi du
parti a liberal democrat pour rappel ces
élections se sont tenues en fin de
semaine dernière sur trois jours et avec
la possibilité dans certaines régions de
voter via internet ce scrutin a fait
face à des accusations de fraude
également de manque de transparence de
la part de l'opposition tandis que le
kremlin lui s'est félicité de la probité
de cette élection donc rendez vous un
petit peu plus tard dans la journée pour
avoir le mot le mot final de cette
élection législatif